[Música]
perdonar parte de la deuda que tienen
cerca de 45 millones de estudiantes en
eeuu esa fue una de las promesas de
campaña de joe biden y que hace una
semana anunció como una realidad la
continuación sería hasta por 20 mil
dólares para quienes cumplan ciertos
requisitos y la casa blanca afirma que
así ayuda a compensar el daño económico
que dejó la pandemia del cob y 19 pero
sus críticos tildan la acción como un
guiño electoral para ganarse los votos
de la juventud en los comicios de medio
término de noviembre y también ponen un
manto de duda sobre si el mandatario
tiene la capacidad legal para condonar
préstamos federales saltándose al
congreso es entonces el perdón de la
deuda un alivio para los más
desfavorecidos o una herramienta
electoral con dinero del estado lo
analizaremos en el debate de hoy antes
veamos un informe en el que nuestro
periodista andrés triviño nos explica en
qué consiste el plan de iovine
un alivio para los estudiantes
estadounidenses me quitaron un peso de
encima principalmente para mis padres
porque los estresa mucho
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que perdonará deudas de préstamos a
estudiantes universitarios y recién
graduados el gobierno federal estima que
43 millones de personas se verán
beneficiadas del plan
el costo total para asistir a una
universidad pública de 4 años se ha
triplicado durante los últimos 40 años
en lugar de financiar adecuadamente las
universidades públicas muchos estados
han recortado su apoyo y han reducido la
financiación para sus universidades
estatales dejando que los estudiantes
paguen una mayor parte de la cuenta
esta nueva medida está pensada para
aquellos que ganen menos de 125 mil
dólares de forma individual o 250.000 en
familia anualmente y espera cancelar
10.000 dólares en préstamos y 10.000
adicionales para estudiantes con becas
federales ppl reservadas para quienes
tienen mayores necesidades financieras
el anuncio de bailén ha causado gran
polémica incluso dentro de su mismo
partido
el congreso no le ha dado una
autorización explícita para sus
detractores es visto como un guiño al
voto joven a poco más de dos meses de
las elecciones legislativas mientras
economistas advirtieron que la medida y
aumentar la inflación la que llegó al
8.5 en julio los republicanos pusieron
en duda la autoridad legal del
mandatario para tomar la decisión
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
juan manuel guzmán director de políticas
de los estados de la ong united we dream
y a laura bustamante estudiante actual
de posgrado y manager de campañas y
políticas para new years in the recuerdo
a nuestros televidentes que también
hacen parte de esta conversación deje
sus preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
instagram y facebook en donde nos
encuentran como arroba france24 raya al
piso
o en mi cuenta personal mariah que
aguirre la etiqueta con la que pueden
conversar en nuestras redes es numeral
el debate efe 24 en youtube también
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
saludamos a quienes nos escuchan también
en nuestro podcast y los invito para que
se conecten a nuestros contenidos de
podcast de todo nuestro programa
disponibles en app el podcast spotify
deezer y tuning
y ahora sí empecemos la discusión
hablando de la información general y
comienzo preguntándole a juan manuel
guzmán y también dándole la bienvenida a
nuestro programa juan manuel que falta
para que esta medida entra en vigor y de
dónde saldría el dinero que se estima
que se necesitarán 300 mil millones de
dólares
pero el gobierno federal va a dar
y guías sobre cómo se va a implementar
el perdón a la deuda student estudiantil
entonces hay que esperar
cuáles son los lineamientos
para que las personas puedan aplicar
sabemos que algunas otras personas
tienen a través de su sistema pueden ver
reflejados esos balances a que han sido
realmente han ha sido un alivio el
quitarles ese peso de encima a lo que es
la deuda estudiantil que es un problema
muy grande acá en los eeuu dados los
costos altos de la de la educación
superior acá en eeuu y de donde saldría
este dinero
bueno como todos sabemos este es vienen
son recursos federales que en
en el pasado habían sido utilizados para
salvarles o darles un salvavidas a los
grandes bancos a voces
en este momento estos recursos federales
están siendo utilizados o van a ser
utilizados para darle una salvavidas a
mucha gente de la clase media en la
clase media-baja que va a poder tener un
suspiro
por esta gran y este gran problema es la
deuda estudiantil que como ustedes han
reportado son casi 45 millones de
estadounidenses que sufren de este
agrava nos decía juan manuel entonces
que es un alivio y le quiero dar la
bienvenida a laura bustamante si bien es
un alivio y además fue una promesa de
campaña porque la administración de joe
biden la lanza ahora a tan sólo tres
meses de las elecciones de medio término
en las que se renueva gran parte del
congreso busca el voto joven el
presidente bailén
pues claro que el presente baile está
buscando el voto joven pero nada por de
mono su voto joven es de algo muy
importante como es un electoral muy
grande en este momento en este país
también quiero hablar más el pulso de
los jóvenes inmigrantes o jóvenes como
les llamamos acá en eeuu que son primera
generación vemos que los jóvenes han
sido impactados más que todos los
jóvenes inmigrantes de primera
generación porque procura más montaje
para los que nos damos cuenta eso
programa ayuda a los estudiantes
indocumentados poder estudiar posgrados
después del bachillerato en
universidades de cuatro años pero un
requisito de ese programa es para que
los restantes se puedan quedar en eeuu
necesitamos que estar inscritos en una
universidad y eso lo que ha pasado es en
mucha presta que tienes que sacar
préstamos privados que tienen una tasa
de interés muy alta lo que pasa es que
hay un eso es algo muy importante
estamos viendo en estos los jóvenes y
los jóvenes como los que estamos votando
entonces si el presidente va a ir en que
eres religión obviamente tiene que
hablar sobre sus problemas lo que habló
el compañero antes de algo muy
importante que veo desde esta avenida y
eso lo estaban dando ya a la gente de
los bancos a las grandes empresas pero
los exámenes pongo ayudas como los
estudiantes de ahora somos el futuro
nosotros somos el futuro y hemos visto
este plan nuevo de bailén lo que va a
hacer es que va a ayudar a mucha gente
más que toda la inmigrante y la gente
hasta venir muchos países y que está
tratando desde el parte del futuro este
país pero los republicanos que se oponen
a esta medida han dicho que esto es
hacer política con dineros federales que
respondería a juan manuel
bueno y estoy
muy en desacuerdo con eso como como
había puntualizado en el pasado los
republicanos le han dado salvavidas a
estos grandes bancos estas instituciones
financieras y la verdad ayudar a la
clase media a la clase trabajadora a la
clase que está a las personas de higuey
es algo tan importante para la gente que
ha estado sufriendo los embates de una
economía muy difícil en el sentido de
que hemos sufrido una pandemia y encima
hay muchas deudas entonces esto
realmente da una oportunidad a la gente
a que pueda poder pensar en
a ahorrar para comprar su casa tener
suficientes recursos para tener su
primer vehículo e incluso hacer
inversiones poner su primera en una
pequeña empresa entonces el impacto a la
clase media la clase media baja es muy
fuerte a la clase trabajadora
obviamente que los republicanos sean los
grandes millonarios no les va a gustar
y que tiene por decir laura al respecto
y claro no agregó a ese punto que el
gobierno
lo que estamos haciendo acá es una
responsabilidad del gobierno el gobierno
está respondiendo a una crisis el pueblo
entonces el gobierno necesita que pensar
creativamente en cómo solucionar eso
entonces estamos hablando sobre el
impacto general general de generaciones
está impactando la economía a largo
plazo que es lo que está pasando la
gente no está comprando para gas no está
invirtiendo la bolsa de valores y la
gente tampoco está teniendo familias
están creciendo parar en pasarse
entender y vos específicamente porque
los préstamos están tan altos que la
gente no pueden no pueden salir de las
casas están viendo con sus papás en
entre 20 a 35 años y es porque
simplemente no les alcanza poder pagar
este préstamo tan alto y es algo que
vemos en este país que uno tiene que ir
a la energía para poder conseguir el
trabajo pero no estamos elevando para
conseguir los trabajos y ahora no
podemos salir de nuestras casas porque
tenemos que pagar esa empresa
y sin duda entonces esta medida
beneficiará sobre todo a quienes se
endeudaron para hacer esos préstamos y
poder ir a la universidad sin embargo
hay una duda sobre la legalidad de la
decisión porque el presidente de byd en
la tomó firmando una acción ejecutiva en
la que ordena la condonación pero ha
habido todo tipo de debates sobre si
tiene el poder o no porque el año pasado
cuando la senadora demócrata elizabeth
ward verne propuso un plan legislativo
para perdonar 50.000 dólares por
prestatario el centro de servicios
legales de la facultad de derecho de la
universidad de harvard afirmó que la ley
de educación superior le daba el poder
al departamento de educación para
condonar dinero pero un asesor del mismo
departamento refutó la idea y explicó
que la competencia es del congreso
porque es el que asignó los fondos de
los préstamos federales que son los que
están en el plan de weyden y además
porque ningún funcionario puede gastar
dinero o no asignado cuando anual que
tanta validez jurídica tiene entonces
una acción ejecutiva de este tamaño sin
que tenga el aval de los legisladores
bueno en este caso vemos la politización
del sector judicial
hemos visto como muchos derechos han
sido
han sido golpeados por las cortes
estamos hablando del derecho a la labor
estamos hablando como programas como el
de programas cosas exitosas que le dan
alivio a la gente a la clase popular
que están siendo
irrumpidas por un sector judicial que
está siendo aprovechado por actores
políticos porque en realidad los actores
políticos que no tienen en este momento
el poder lo único que van a hacer es
tratar de poner una demanda para que las
cortes lo paren eso se va si se si
sucede se pelearían las cortes pero
hasta este momento lo que sabemos es de
que la gente lo necesita el pueblo lo
necesita entonces a través de eso
vamos a ver si las cortes lo paran pero
en este momento como todos sabemos está
en curso
y si bien es un alivio porque saltarse
el debate en el congreso laura
pues simplemente porque como estamos
hablando en este programa es algo que no
es saltarse el presidente más es muy
claro suficiente tiene un poder
ejecutivo pues ese les causan pero vivo
de una manera obviamente pequeñita pero
también no pise el cuerno una persona
porque siente tiene ese deber al pueblo
no instó a él por esa misma propuesta lo
que él hizo y él está cumpliendo parte
no completamente porque él no está
cumpliendo la promesa en totalidad pero
sí la está cumpliendo con parte mente y
es por lo mismo que estamos en un crisis
económico el pueblo de la general la
gente joven el pueblo estudiante de la
clase media en este momento no tiene los
recursos para poder avanzar entonces
algo que se necesita que ser
económicamente para prestarles ayuda al
pueblo crear esa palanca para que la
gente pueda empezar a comprar casas para
que la gente pueda seguir teniendo unas
familias y eso es algo que
él está haciendo que fue parte de lo que
él hizo esa promesa y en ese momento la
está cumpliendo pero más allá de los
beneficios volvamos un poco como a la
legalidad de la medida y es que de hecho
en ese momento cuando la senadora warren
propuso el proyecto la demócrata nancy
pelosi presidenta de la cámara de
representantes dijo que esto que biden
no tenía el poder de condonar préstamos
estudiantiles y ahora dice que el
anuncio del presidente es audaz y que se
alinea con los intereses de los
demócratas porque ese cambio de postura
sabiendo además que pelosi es del mismo
partido de byd en cuando a 9
y ahora vamos con usted entonces
si no claro pues del pueblo no puedo dar
una opinión legal porque yo no soy
abogada ni tampoco puedo hablar sobre
las razones en cuáles pelosi no quiso
cambiar de opinión lo que sí podemos
admitir es que el el pues los votantes
jóvenes están siendo muy claros qué es
lo que ellos necesitan de su gobierno y
ellos están
sabemos que hay unas elecciones de
noviembre entonces qué está haciendo los
jóvenes los jóvenes están demandando lo
que necesitan ellos están diciendo que
quieren que el presidente haga sus
promesas y ya es eso es decisión de cada
político como ellos quieran tomar sus
decisiones y luego haremos sobre todo a
qué sectores de jóvenes beneficia a esta
medida pero antes hablemos de un punto
de economía y es que otra de las
posturas de los críticos es que la
condonación aumentaría la inflación
porque daría más dinero a los
consumidores para gastar la casa blanca
sostiene que este aumento sería ínfimo
cuál cree usted que sería el golpe de la
economía estadounidense perdonar cerca
de 3 mil millones de dólares teniendo en
cuenta además la inflación histórica que
alcanzó el país en junio y que ha sido
la más alta de los últimos 40 años
pues cuando estamos hablando de
inflación qué es lo que está pasando lo
que está pasando es que si obviamente
vamos a tener un poco más dinero para
que la gente vuelva al mercado pero eso
lo necesitamos porque en este momento
nadie está comprando casas todo el mundo
está vendiendo y la razón por qué añadí
está comprando casas porque la
generación que les corresponde comprar
casas propiedad es invertir en raíz no
lo está haciendo simplemente porque no
son aprobados para los préstamos que se
necesitan porque tienen tantos préstamos
y están tan altos en ese sentido por los
préstamos de estudiantes entonces no es
no estamos viendo estamos una economía
que está prácticamente quieta y dando
ese alivio lo que va a ser el para
volver a reinventar y poder
dar como dar es ese ese dinero adicional
para que los estudiantes sí puedan
construir al mercado y no estén pagando
intereses a bancos que ya tienen
suficiente dinero y tener suficientes
ayudas adicionales del gobierno
ustedes dicen que este dinero lo sacan
de donde eran la financiación para los
bancos sin embargo los republicanos
sostienen que esta medida beneficiaría a
estudiantes ricos y que a la final es la
clase media y pobre también además de la
rica la que pagaría esto a través de sus
impuestos cuando a nivel es esto cierto
bueno es que eso no tiene sentido porque
los millonarios no tienen esa deuda los
que se adeudan son la gente que no puede
pagar los costos altos de la educación
entonces eso no tiene sentido
es importante recalcar de que
obviamente es un tema profundo no
estamos diciendo que lo que hizo vaivén
va a solucionar todo el problema hay
muchas cosas más que hay que hacer es un
problema muy profundo pero le da un gran
alivio a una gran parte de la del sector
de la población y a veces uno se pone a
pensar por qué
en este caso algunos conservadores se
oponen a libios que le afectan
directamente a la gente obviamente no
vamos a dudar de que quizás hayan
cálculos políticos el hecho sin embargo
el hecho de que la gente que hemos visto
a través de las redes sociales gente
llorando gente y personas de a pie
que han dicho esto me cambia la vida
aunque sean 10.000 o 20.000 dólares que
en el en el caso de job especialmente
los jóvenes que están iniciando su
carrera
eso es la diferencia entre
y poder comprarse un vehículo en poder
pagar la renta o no entonces es bien
importante que si bien es un tema muy
profundo este es un gran alivio para
muchas personas en los eeuu millones de
personas pero todavía no se conocen los
detalles de esa medida por ejemplo hasta
cuándo se va a condonar esos préstamos o
desde qué periodo se acogen juan manuel
a qué se debe esta ausencia de
información por parte de la casa blanca'
bueno como toda política pues necesita
pasar por un tema técnico burocrático
cada vez que gobierno perdón en este
caso el efectivo lanzó un decreto o una
orden ejecutiva pues tiene que haber
lineamientos porque obviamente es es
bien complicado y tiene que ser un
detalle de pasos quién es y quién es no
cuánto tiempo entonces ese proceso
obviamente el gobierno federal tiene que
dar
a lineamientos especialmente el
ejecutivo el departamento de educación
y obviamente va a tomar cierto cierto
cierto tiempo pero sin embargo es de que
de nuevo en el punto ellos de que la
gente dice y es importante para poder y
para poder dar una línea a muchas
personas que en este momento están
pasando a través de un momento de crisis
no ustedes bien han explicado que las
deudas universitarias en eeuu son
millonarias y que son uno de los grandes
problemas del país y hay otro tema allí
y es la equidad racial y es que hay un
sector que dice que las medidas deberían
estar dirigidas a la población
afroamericana y que si así no se logra
pues realmente no se cierra esa brecha
de raza que existe en el país la casa
blanca por su lado defiende que la
condonación va a aumentar la actividad
racial citando estudios que muestran que
cerca del 70% de los becarios ppl son
afroamericanos y recordemos que las
becas pell son las más grandes del país
y además están dirigidas a la población
más vulnerable laura usted opina que
esta condonación aumenta o no la
inequidad racial
claro que aumenta la igualdad racial y
más que todo porque como había un
poquito anterior
tienes unas personas que necesitamos
sacar préstamos para poder atender la
universidad son la gente afro latina con
los inmigrantes o la gente que son
primera generación y por qué porque
muchas veces esas mismas generaciones
nuestros papás los papás de esta cuña
nunca ni en la universidad no con
estudiaba tan este país entonces también
vemos en acá en eeuu no hay suficientes
personas que puedan explicar a las
personas en lo que están haciendo es un
préstamo unos días de un préstamo que
son las cosas entonces lo que estamos
viendo es que la gente inmigrante la
gente afroamericana ellos van sacan
estos préstamos van a la universidad
porque es lo que pensamos que tenemos
que hacer entonces ellos son las
placentas de bajos recursos y muchas
veces me recuerdo que muchos inmigrantes
no no son elegibles para muchas de las
ayudas
para los estudiantes entonces que les
toca que hacer para ellos poder ir a la
universidad tienen que sacar préstamos
privados entonces todo esto es una
póliza una política que realmente es y
está ayudando a la comunidad afro latina
y también a los inmigrantes pero si
ustedes bien dice que hay sectores más
afectados como los afro latinos los
migrantes los afroamericanos porque
entonces no va a ser una política
sectorizada dedicada únicamente para
estos segmentos de la población y al
contrario abrirlo para todos quienes
tienen deudas federales laura
lo vemos es porque también a la misma
vez y tras eso es una manera de no
excluir a la comunidad porque de todas
maneras hay otras personas que de pronto
no son de esta raza que también están
pasando por lo mismo entonces la idea es
inglesas tuvieran las personas sino que
ayudaran a las personas que más se
puedan pero sabemos que esta política es
específica para lo que vivimos antes es
que los applets y no sé son los que dan
y los afroamericanos son los que han
aplicado a la mayoría de ellos son los
planificados los cuales 40 entonces
veamos una póliza en la cual estamos
llegando a llegando a la mayoría del
pueblo pero de todas maneras vemos que
si cierran sk de
la cualidad racial y juan manuel cómo
cerrar esta inequidad racial con
programas y con donaciones segmentados
por población o abierta al público en
general como la que tiene el presidente
white
es necesario
ponerlo no tanto en ese tema en ese
ámbito sino de que
es necesario tener una conversación
profunda acerca de la educación superior
porque esto afecta a través a todos
afecta a latinos afecta proamericanos
afecta a diferentes grupos raciales en
los eeuu y la educación superior se está
volviendo cada vez más inalcanzable
nosotros hemos abogado y abogamos por
que haya
educación gratuita pública en vez de
seguir
invirtiendo en muchísimas cosas que los
gobiernos invierten que a veces no
tienen sentido es necesario invertir en
la educación han habido recortes lo
primero que se recorta en los estados
cuando hay alguna recesión cuando falta
cuando hay algún déficit fiscal lo
primero que sufre es la educación y se
ha dejado de invertir en la educación a
nivel estatal y si no hay una inversión
seria y el pollo a los estudiantes
entonces este tema va a continuar
el alivio es importante ha venido en un
momento muy crucial para muchas personas
pero esta conversación profunda hacia el
futuro envuelve muchas cosas y hay que
invertir en la educación y hay que dar
la oportunidad a la gente de a pie de
tener la oportunidad de ir a la
educación no sólo aquellos que lo pueden
pagar o que pueden prestarse o que van a
tener que hundirse porque van a tener
que prestarse 50.000 60.000 70.000
dólares a los 22 años no tiene sentido
quiero ahondar en un punto que usted
estaba mencionando y es usted dice
literalmente la educación superior es
cada vez más inalcanzable en eeuu y de
hecho los precios de las carreras
universitarias en instituciones públicas
se han triplicado los costos desde los
años 80 según datos del departamento de
educación de eeuu mientras que las becas
pell pasaron de cubrir el 80 por ciento
de todos los gastos a tan sólo el 29 por
ciento en carreras de 4 años en
instituciones públicas como atacar
entonces juanma los problemas
estructurales de acceso a la educación
más allá de condonar 10.000 o 20.000
dólares
bueno en primero primer parte el primer
sentido es es necesario evitar esos
recortes a la educación hay que invertir
en la educación los estados los
gobernadores y las legislaturas
necesitan invertir en vez de sacar ese
dinero de la educación
número 2 se tiene que poner en una se
necesita hacer auditorías no solamente a
las universidades públicas sino hay
muchas entidades privadas que han
convertido a la educación superior en un
negocio y muchas de estas universidades
no necesariamente son muy buenas pero
ofrecen muchísimas cosas
y al final la gente termina endeudándose
para fiestas e instituciones privadas
tercero es es necesario de que las
universidades pongan y dejen de invertir
en recursos en cosas como estadios cosas
que aumentan la experiencia del
estudiante no necesariamente su
actividad académica
muchas universidades están invirtiendo
muchísimo dinero en cosas que la verdad
no tiene sentido y de nuevo hay un ayuno
como una perspectiva de negocio antes
que actividad académica
y ahora el cuerpo no tiene ninguna
prenda en rapidito el último punto creo
que necesitamos también un cambio
cultural porque muchas familias y esto
también sucede en las familias migrantes
no tienes que ir a la universidad sí o
sí porque solamente ese es el camino hay
que también nosotros
reflexionar y ver de qué carreras
técnicas hay negocios y ponemos y
educamos a nuestros niños diciéndoles
que la que el único camino el único
camino al éxito es la universidad hay
varios caminos entonces esa es una
conversación te di cuatro puntos pero
creo que hay más sí y ahora para ir con
laura dentro de este plan de tres
aristas que propone white en uno de
ellos es reducir el costo de las
universidades y castigar a las
instituciones que superen montos
exagerados como lo mencionaba a juan
manuel sin embargo el presidente y
tampoco la casa blanca especifican cómo
lograrlo laura cómo hacer esto en un
país como eeuu donde hay autoridades
estatales y no sólo la federal
claro necesitan bueno en eso el
presidente puede asignar una ley federal
y obviamente no quería trabajar con el
congreso pero esas son las cosas en
muchos gobernadores también han estado
cuando de ayudar y también vemos que hay
un programa muy similar en los niveles
estatales por hablarlo sobre nueva
yersey que es donde vivo que vemos que
los gobernadores la legislatura a nivel
estatal de ayuda a las universidades
públicas para poder rebajar el precio
del anual de la educación entonces
podemos ver un sistema así muy similar
federal entonces si hay y hay sistemas y
hay todo lo que ha pasado lo hemos visto
lo hemos visto y todavía existe lo que
lo que podemos hacer es los
sistemas que sabemos que funcionan y que
han ayudado a muchos estudiantes jove
una energía pública hacer lo mismo pero
podemos hacerlo al nivel nacional
entonces eso es una opción y también
aquí requiere que el presidente también
cerca mente con los gobernadores para
poder mejor entender cuál es el estatus
en esas en esos estados estatales laura
por entonces viendo todas estas fallas
estructurales en el acceso a la
educación se puede decir que una
condonación de la deuda es tan sólo un
incentivo paliativo de la situación
pues no solamente tenemos que tomar y
ser muy conscientes de que lo que hago
juanma en el juan manuel anteriormente
que esto es solamente un pago no estamos
diciendo que estás toda la solución y
que ya de aquí ahora ya todo el mundo va
a ser bien no lo que tenemos que hacer
es eso es un paso pero tenemos que hacer
más tenemos que mirar a todas las
opciones necesitamos que ver cómo
podemos rebajar cómo podemos aportar
recursos en cosas que no está ayudando a
la gente lo que es en el sector
académico y también sin tener que tener
mucho cuidado con las instituciones que
han tratado de limitar y tomar ventaja
de los estudiantes y también los bancos
están usando los los
de las tasas de intereses a niveles tan
altos que lo que realmente quiebra a la
gente que saca préstamos y usted
mencionaba que existen otros programas
similares en eeuu y uno de ellos también
muy conocido es la condonación de
préstamos por servicio público ope tlf
por sus siglas en inglés y el presidente
joe biden anunció que deberían reparar
ese programa que existe desde el 2007 y
es que tiene una serie de requisitos
bastante largos que impiden que la
mayoría de beneficiarios posibles se
acerquen a él y de hecho hay estudios
que muestran que sólo cubre al 1% de la
población juan manuel en qué consiste
ese programa y por qué va a ir en habla
de arreglarlo cuáles son sus problemas
mira no estoy tan familiarizado con el
programa pero sé que él
básicamente da una oportunidad aquellas
personas que se gradúan y hacen servicio
público trabajan para entidades públicas
entonces a través de eso muchas personas
pueden acceder a alivio de la deuda no a
si el presidente y es cierto de que
muchos de estos requisitos son demasiado
complicados
entonces no le da la oportunidad a la
gente que está haciendo servicio público
de poder tener aliviar su deuda no
entonces si es necesario
reparar a hacerlos más claros más
fáciles para que la idea tiene que ser
de abrir lo más posible las
oportunidades verdad no debería ser
cerrar y ahí a veces en los procesos
burocráticos de aplicación para estos
beneficios en muchas veces la la
filosofía es cómo vamos a hacer que
menos personas
se beneficie si un 1% se beneficia
entonces no es tan exitoso no entonces
hay que abrir eso y dar la oportunidad a
las personas de que puedan acceder en
este caso por el programa de servicio
público y cuál es el incentivo a futuro
que puede generar en las instituciones
públicas el hecho de que el estado
federal pague o pague parte de ese
crédito que tienen podrían las
universidades aumentar los precios
sabiendo que el estado va a pagar parte
de ellos laura usted qué opina
pues eso lo que hablamos de un cambio
comprensivo si uno entonces no podemos
solamente
eliminar la deuda pero también tiene que
haber cambios sistema sistemáticos para
que las entidades universidades no
puedan hacer eso y no vayan a tener
ventaja entonces tiene que tenemos que
tener los dos o sea que ese ese es un
primer buen paso pero se requiere hacer
cambios sistemáticos a lo largo y por
todo el país no puede ser estatal no
puede ser solamente en un estado en otro
estado por eso es lo que esto es una
responsabilidad del presidente también
es la responsabilidad del congreso y los
líderes los senadores no vamos a decir
que solamente bailen tiene esa
responsabilidad los congresistas y los
senadores también tienen esa
responsabilidad porque esto va a seguir
continuando si no llegamos y no llegamos
a eso entonces vamos a estar en el mismo
y para ir cerrando nuestro programa ya
quiero preguntarles por las conclusiones
del programa empezando por juan manuel
cuál es su visión sobre esta condonación
y que pasaría o si usted considera o no
se va a seguir implementando
bueno el alivio a la deuda estudiantil
es algo que es necesario era urgente
creo que muchas que muchas personas se
van a poder beneficiar especialmente la
clase media la clase media baja y va a
tener un impacto muy fuerte y muy
positivo en el país a la larga es
necesario como habíamos mencionado tener
un debate mucho más profundo para que
los costos de la educación no sigan
incrementando en la forma que se han
incrementado en los últimos 30 ó 40 años
que como hemos dicho se ha criticado
en este sentido si bien los eeuu tienen
universidades de ese nombre
de qué sirve tener universidades de ese
nombre cuando tu propia gente tu propio
pueblo no puede acceder los entonces ese
tipo de cosas es necesario exponerlo al
tema de debate y ojalá que en los
próximos meses años se pueda aminorar el
tema de la de la educación superior acá
y ahora y muy brevemente cuál es su
conclusión
la conclusión es simplemente que este
programa necesita que ayudar y van a
ayudar a la gente que lo necesita que
son los afro latinos los afroamericanos
la comunidad inmigrante entonces lo que
necesitamos es ver programas similares y
más avanzados y más avanzados como este
para que la comunidad con la cual se
está endeudando para este país sea
recompensado laura bustamante y juan
manuel guzmán gracias por acompañarnos y
gracias también a nuestros televidentes
sigan con más información en france 24
[Música]